well if you turn on the local news here
in Germany you're likely to see reports
on gas reserve levels that is the
combined amount of gas held in various
underground reserves around the nation
compared to their capacity
it's not especially riveting coverage
but for many businesses it's of vast
importance should gas levels fall too
fast say after especially cold
temperatures their gas could then be
turned off as a rationing measure and
some firms don't have alternatives
Germany's gas storage facilities never
attracted much attention before now
they're at the center of public debate
and for good reason the country's energy
security depends on them this winter
for German businesses like this break
Factory in Bavaria production is
dictated by the levels of Germany's gas
reserves
[Music]
that's a major thing we checked that
almost every day and we're it's it's how
we run our business here we need it
without gas the ovens here stay cold
the gas goes through these yellow lines
right through here into the oven
and then it Heats
inside the bricks you can see the fire
it fires the bricks so the bricks burn
full reserves ensure steady brick
production even during the winter months
when Germany Imports less gas than it
uses
just a few kilometers from the brick
Factory in voipasback lies Germany's
deepest gas storage facility
oh
it's a porous Rock gas storage what's
above ground is just the tip the most
important part lies three thousand
meters below there the gas is stored in
Porous Rock that's millions of years old
it soaks up the gas like a sponge
impermeable rocks and water around it
act like a natural barrier and prevent
leaks
the gas levels are closely monitored at
all times
today we're at 99.2 percent it takes
about 150 days to fill or empty the
storage facility
this way the voice back gas storage
could Supply up to 300 000 households
with gas for one year most of the time
the uneasy question in the back of my
mind is what if we have a really cold
winter because if it's really cold we'll
have problems even when the reservoir is
full
that could see Flames go out and
factories close despite Germany's
state-of-the-art storage facilities
[Music]
hitting loystein joins me from the
political risk consultancy Eurasia group
he's director there for energy climate
and resources handing welcome to the
show
um should Germans be optimistic or
pessimistic when they look at the way
gas supply is shaping up this winter
um hi so I I think Germany can look
fairly optimistically into the into the
early start of 2023 uh for sure gas
consumption uh just before Christmas was
really high but that's because it was
really cold
um demand this week after Christmas
um before New Year's Eve will be really
low because industrial gas consumption
will go down because everyone's on
holiday and the latest weather forecast
is for relatively mild weather for the
next couple of weeks and gas inventories
are still about 86 full so we should be
all right
we've often heard that next winter will
be even harder do you share that opinion
and why is that if that's the case
that depends actually a little bit on
the rest this winter because if it flips
to be really cold over the next couple
of weeks and then stays cold for the
remainder of this winter then gas
inventories will have been depleted
quite far and that will mean that
Germany its utilities must spend most of
next year refilling the inventories
again without any rushing gas probably
so that could be a problem uh but as a
so far we estimate now that um even if
it turns quite cold again that Germany
also should be right next winter gas
event is will will be refilled the LNG
the liquefied ship gas is now coming to
Germany and most supply has been secured
but it's going to be expensive and that
is going to be a problem for next year
because Energy prices will remain pretty
high
there has been uh this looming threat of
rationing at least for maybe late winter
or late fall I should say that's sort of
gone away so far at the same time have
we seen that people have been responding
to this threat that they've been saving
especially businesses and households
what have we seen there have there been
attempts to really pull back
it happened they've been quite
impressive at times here and I think
that this was mentioned and so
households have definitely tried to
reduce consumption until it got really
cold because if it gets cold you need to
heat that's it's a matter of life but
households have reduced consumption
versus their normal levels and so have
industry uh most companies that we work
with and that we talk to have made
really active plans to reduce their
consumption immediately and buy as much
as possible without reducing the
industrial output I.E causing a
recession so this is uh one of the major
successes in probably avoiding uh
rationing this winter is it's reduction
in consumption by industry and
households we saw a story there before
we came to you about a brick maker
dependent upon gas should rationing take
place and we can't say to what extent it
would take place but how devastating
would that be to a largely industrial
economy here in Germany
so this is a risk because especially
small to mid-sized companies um that
have less space to save money they have
less of a cash cushion and they can't
just shut down for a few weeks if their
family owned that this is this is your
life and that is a risk and of course
energy intensive businesses like you
mentioned the brick makers glass makers
cement makers this is um this is an
issue this is a problem
um a rationing would be a problem would
force someone to shut down but the
bigger problem is probably uh several
years of high prices that are going to
hurt them and that will probably require
some further government support next
year
all right that was hitting leichstein
from the Eurasia group thank you very
much
thank you
well speaking of energy in Germany the
build out of Renewables is moving slowly
despite a new push prompted by the war
in Ukraine and the country's dependence
on gas
whether it's rising costs or Germany's
often tenacious bureaucracy almost
everyone involved from Network operators
to business owners and communities
believe things could move faster
Harmony is not known for its sunshine
and yet here near Berlin a new solar
Park is being built the approval process
for the park took just six months could
this set a precedent for renewable
energy projects
the fact is that there is still a great
deal of leeway to delay individual
approval procedures
[Music]
rules for cultural heritage protection
are one possibility
if there is a hill somewhere in a field
which no Layman would even recognize as
a monument this means that in the end
there cannot be renewable development in
a radius of several kilometers
surrounded I see that as nothing more
than prevention politics and not very
forward-thinking foreign
and what about wind power Germany's most
important renewable energy source this
year wind turbines with an output of
around 2 200 megawatts were commissioned
enough to supply around 2 million
households with electricity
next year 12 000 megawatts will be put
out to Tender that's the enormity of the
task the administration is going to have
to shift up the gear
Germany's electricity grid is expanding
at a snail's pace and this is holding up
the energy transition
the government has simplified many
things but there are often problems when
it comes to implementation
until the measures actually take effect
we assume that at least as far as large
solar parks and large wind farms are
concerned it will take at least three to
four years until they actually have an
effect yet
the solar park near Berlin is to start
supplying electricity next year with an
output of 20 megawatts Germany is
picking up the pace in the energy
transition but needs to find a second
gear